I will end up putting this on YouTube
most likely so for you to people for
twitch people this is a match in choker
oh that's not a good start maybe I
waited too long or not all the match
starts okay
I'm playing the one the only the hot
French G also known as hot french guy
also known as Nakamura honestly I didn't
really do much preparation for this
match but we'll see how it goes let's
start by checking I'm gonna play it safe
and along the way because I know there's
a lot of people who are maybe not
familiar with this game along the way
I'll try and explain how the game works
explain my thought process we're
starting in the betting phase so he's
raising so the interesting thing here
I'll kind of a call if I'm Delta Queen
then that's basically known as a palace
and that would give me another queen but
I'm dealt upon that's the worst card I
could possibly be dealt and okay I'm
gonna play it safe I might end up
folding actually if he bets cuz I don't
want to he bets 500 now he has a better
hand than me I'm gonna fold yeah what do
I have I have yeah I fold
yes okay husband fortune starts but I
probably could have lost more chips if I
if I bet or if I called so it's just
getting underway I'm gonna be
conservative in the beginning there
won't be too much interaction with the
twitch chats oh it's called whatever get
the blind is oh okay this is a very good
starting hand and I like to think in
terms of value so this is this is
already
points I'll see if he wants to be
aggressive he checks okay so playing
safe and he's the first bet so he has to
disclose some information here he checks
again let's bet let's bet the pot I do
want to thank choker for sponsoring this
they've been very supportive in getting
streamers on board to play this game and
it's still a relatively new app but I've
been doing some streams I had one
YouTube video just over a month ago
which was my first stream let's call
let's yeah start the next hand this is
another good starting hand there's only
four queens no Alexa be quiet there's
only four queens out of the 44 cards in
the deck so being Delta Queen is um well
I think that's about it what less than
10% chance let's all to raise let's mean
raise I feel like naka is better than me
I definitely a chest but probably also
poker I know he's played like one World
Series of Poker so I know I have a big
opponent to take down
and yeah the reason for the delay is so
that the chat can't spoil what cards
what pieces my opponent has this is a
really good hand
what's the pot we bet let me back up ah
she's playing conservatively I might as
well try and take him down look value is
this this is 19 points okay he calls
okay so we're gonna have our first chest
face this is what happens when we get to
the river
no one folds and okay so if he called he
be probably has a relatively strong hand
I think my son up is 2 to fianchetto my
bishop he's doing the same thing it
would be funny if we have the same cards
it's good to see he has two pawns as
well yeah shout out to Brian for
answering some some questions
I know people just joining don't realize
there's a delay ooh that was that the
promoted rook okay and also he's running
to check me I should put a truck on like
c8 probably work on c8 so gardening Rock
bhi carding Bishop c6 check if he has a
queen then oh he has a knight okay this
is beautiful
okay time to take down naka in chess
let's put the Queen I think on e7 yeah
okay
now I'm curious if he'll play on or I'll
just resign um okay he respects me a
little bit that's nice so that was that
was a very quick chess face wasn't worth
playing on I would resign too I mean it
happens okay so I'm I'm ahead in ships
cuz I won a relatively big pot another
Queen been getting good cards I think I
should keep playing aggressively
I think I'll call I'll actually maybe
I'll be tricky these are such good cards
I'll try and make it seem that I'm weak
okay this is amazing hand but I don't
want to like come off as too strong I'm
hoping he bets here and then I'll just
call I have position on him
it's a very important concept in poker
when the opponent bets first it means
you have some advantage if he bets here
again oh wait oh now he has position on
me I guess it goes back and forth I'm
gonna chat I'm gonna set up a trap if he
bets and I'll race please bets please
yeah okay now ah do I just call or do I
raise cuz I don't want to him tab like a
monster hands I think I'll raise all
rings now if he goes all-in
it's a difficult spot okay this is a
huge pot this is 7,000 chips I'm a
little bit scared but okay what to do
let's put the bishop here I think Bishop
on c2 is a good square because I'm I
have to checking ideas g6 and 84 he has
a pawn that's a good start let's put a
992
this is very good sign
I want to put a queen on each one but
maybe I should I should start with the
Knights pieces can only be placed in the
first two rings
I think he's realizing here that he's
probably busted because what's his best
guess he could have two queens but
that's very unlikely if he has rooking
Queen which is the next best I'm still
just crushing him he's a bishop okay I'm
just crushing him debating I have to put
my bishop on a dark square so this is
the only logical dark square could put
it on c1 but I could actually put it on
b2 ob2 is really interesting and then
put the Queen on a1 because I move first
yeah Bishop on b2 should just be winning
she's never threatening h1 because my
knight controls h1 you have a queen on a
one that's coming next
well here's a rook that's hilarious yeah
Queen on any one man I wouldn't be
surprised if he resigns again it's just
devastation for black
okay this is a very good start he's a
knight or no a promoted Knight
okay so I'm just crushing I think I
should start with some that was kind of
a tricky move let's just take a bishop
if he takes on c2 i have queen a which
just wins yeah yeah we're not seeing
much chess like what I've played I
played one move totals I think like this
game if it's played at a high level
there won't be much chess so a lot of it
comes down to Benning let's call
whatever
I haven't Elton another until I'm being
dealt very good cards and I have a very
healthy chip advantage like a leaf
thanks for subbing I'm gonna call I
don't want to get like two pot committed
oh so a third pawn gets promoted to a
rook so this is already looking nice
let's let's check I'll let him be
aggressive like I could bully him now
I'm just gonna call as I have such a big
chip of me that's another very good
hands I think the average hand is valued
at 16 points and this is I do matter
this is nice it's all in
I mean he's coming across is very strong
I have to call I mean this is I don't
have much time - let's call people are
saying let's go people watching might
already see maybe there's some delay
people on on YouTube in the future you
should watch both videos at once to see
both of our commentary okay let's put
the pawn here please have another pawn
oh he hasn't Knight oh that's not a good
sign that means he probably doesn't have
any more pawns I probably shouldn't have
called the hall in I'll also leave a
link there should be a link or a choker
command in the twitch chat but there's a
link to how to play choker or like a
choker guy in which people can check out
I'll leave the link in the video
description - on YouTube oh this is a
very good sign I might just be winning
here um wait he's white he moves first I
have to be careful where to put the rook
not sure whether to put it I should
probably I don't know I don't think it
matters too much maybe b8 is safer or
maybe see yeah I'm putting it here is
one more piece to place if he has a
queen I'm still a material if he has a
queen he's debating maybe between H 1
and a2
yeah okay so he has a queen so I'm up to
exchange Oh he puts it okay so he's
attack my bishop I have to put my queen
on h8 and then chess will will begin so
this isn't trivial to win but it's a
good situation of a rook and Bishop for
two nights
okay queen bee sevens a good move after
the very cognizant of time as well to
play this move he's guarding each one
which is kind of annoying what I want to
do is bring my queen back to happiness
the Queen wants to be more in the center
but it's it's doing something on a
change I also want to keep the time
advantage because he's fast he's the
number one looks player in the world at
least in terms of rating but this is
nice the positions like very simplified
like we just have in hanging game can i
play Bishop c3 Bishop c3 I think is
reasonable and then if King f1 I'll play
Queen h3
I'm thinking Bishop d4 here there's also
rook t4r f d4 93 orchid I'm guarding
Queen C a which is nice trying to
calculate your FD for Rick d4 Knight
takes her g4 is just winning I don't
want to take too much time this is
actually a bullet game now oh he is he
for but before I can take on d3 I took
way too much time here but it looks nice
93 and there's no Queen c8
oh I'm not threatening Nate though I
just mess up okay I visit before moving
way too slowly
maybe Bishop d2 actually making it weird
so there's no Queen CA which is good
turning the night I just want to
simplify I want to play rock h4 two tix
with night so I'll play this okay yeah
it's it's winning but I have 46 seconds
and it's not easy to move fast
oh okay
as we can see let's play this move he's
just going for the dirty flag by g5
it's got some g5 emotes yeah I don't
want to get dirty flags at the very
least I should draw this just by
simplifying I'm keeping my rook I think
what's what's the right technique just
moving the pawns up I move the pawns up
too quickly I allow some outposts let's
bring the King around yeah yeah and the
night comes to e5 but the nice thing is
I can only sacrifice like rook for night
and pawn
nine of sevens annoying I just wanted to
play out for I don't know what I'm doing
this is so annoying I know what he's
doing he wants to dirty flag me I think
I just have to simplify this is so
annoying okay let's get the rook to f3
wait this is close he's gonna play 95 oh
ok I want to play rook I want to play
pawn to 5 and just simplify I can't
offer a draw unfortunately is he gonna
take he's probably gonna take mmm I want
to go for f4
maybe it'll smooth that's probably that
decision I shouldn't have taken too much
time earlier no I'm gonna lose this he's
gonna dirty flag me that's so
unfortunate I was up the exchange - OH
gonna win the pawn yes I'm gonna win the
pawn let's do this it's still a draw
though practicing my own speed before I
flag I still need him before I flag no
legal moves the pot splits that's what
happens when there's a job what a game I
should have I was up material he's so
good at losing what you do ok so much
adrenaline
at least I didn't lose that it could
have very easily lost that given in the
King pawn ending okay this is a
better-than-average hand I'm gonna try
and calm down after that one he raises
so strong I mean raising signifies he
probably has a queen that's not good
card that's not a good car and if he
bets I fold his check oh he checks oh
it's the nice thing about like being
behind chips
okay the pawn gets promoted to rook this
is still a below average hand I'm not
sure if he it depends how much he bets
if I call her oh we're gonna have
another chest face so he's not so strong
we could have like similar value hands
let's sum okay let's move quicker this
time
except the squad mode oh can we start
squad before you see squad no I've Syria
I was not talking to you okay I just
accepted squad mode hopefully that
improves the viewing experience for some
people it says naca is a squad leader
yeah pre-move will be hopefully enabled
in the future what to do here can i
generate any threats oh I could play
rook p1 ooh yeah because if he has a
queen he has to defend the rook and I
take the rook and play rook AIDS okay so
this is looking pretty draw I probably
don't want to trade okay I'll trade one
but I don't want to trade two rooks
who's working Bishop R is generally
better than rook and Knight but with the
pawns on my close proximity I don't want
to get outplayed oh no he lost
connection Oh
reconnect okay sometimes when you lose
connection it can crash the game but
it's good to see it didn't crash Oh what
to do my my pawns don't want to be on
light squares I don't know why I played
g4 I should just kind of play safe
I'm scared he's gonna dirty flag me
again okay I mean position is solid and
I'll put the King on e3 maybe on d2
he's gonna play rook h2 maybe he's
running Knight takes f3 so sneaky I
don't want to play rook probably a 7 so
now there's no night c4 for potential
maybe this should be 5 going after d7
might have some idea of playing out for
play f4 takes king f-35 I think it kind
of works hope I do not miss calculating
yeah cuz I 500 win the pawn back and I
might have a 4 in the end trying to
calculate e 4 I mean there's some rook
check there's some knight check I don't
think it hurts me I'm just trying to
simplify there also there's no
recovering because always play Bishop f1
I am down on time which is unfortunate
but again I'm just trying to simplify
and the the pawns are on GC squares for
the bishop this move there's rook h2 and
then King g3 it's also that move that's
a good move play Bishop c4 I also always
have a 5 yeah I'll play Bishop c4 if
rook c3 I play d5 and then win d6 pawn
oh no I got forked no how do I get
forked why did I play Bishop c4 I forgot
about 93 that's so unfortunate I should
probably just resign
oh there's one stalemate trap rook g3
King h5 and I'll try and sack my rook
please fall for it rook taking six in
column
he's too good I can't even dirty flag
him resign oh wait no no no cuz he he's
walking into stalemate again
or I'm walking into stalemate
no I should respect his ability to in
this position okay that's unfortunate
also thanks for the bits and shoutouts
who who cheered bits it was tagged it
was Artemis prime know like ice cream
Lulu food thanks people yeah I have to
play faster I was kind of brutal I'm
still up on chips two pawns this is like
the worst hand right it's a really bad
hand if he raises I just fold from 1k
yeah I fold yeah if you're just joining
and you're confused
I would hope people can explain what's
happening in in the stream anyway yeah
this game it's a combination of chess
and poker there's different phases this
is a betting phase ideally I want to
maximize the the value of the pot when I
have good cards let's call these are
good cards I'll let him doing the bit or
do the betting she's been playing
aggressively recently ok another good
card Oh
so three rooks on the third row gets
demoted to a pawn this is still better
than average I think what I have 14
points yeah let's
because okay so what's the value there's
17
it's a better-than-average hands I think
all I'll bet half no that's a week let's
let the full pot I don't see what he
does so he raises he knows that if he
has like an equal hand he beats me in
chess but this is better than average I
think I'm getting like jisun tolerance
like I kind of committed myself by
betting there yeah let's put the pawn
let's pull up on f3 this is a decent
strategy when you just have one pawn I
think it helps to have a pawn chain like
this and there's all the potential for
like the rook to create some both rooks
to create some battery I'll put it on
out to the knight is usually good when
it's next to the king to help defend the
King okay there's three pawns I'm scared
he might have a queen hmm okay I have a
tricky idea I'm gonna put a rook on a1
hoping that he puts a rook on b8 and
then I'll put a bishop on on each to
also the time starts kicking in this
phase so I have to um I'm gonna make an
effort to keep some time advantage
he hasn't night okay so this is looking
good so far
hmm I'm gonna put a yeah I mean I'd
follow the same idea now if if he puts
like a rook on G I put a bishop on a -
yeah okay Bishop on a - and now like if
he has a queen he can't really defend
the rook I guess he could counter-attack
but we do play Queen on g7 no a queen on
g7 and worse am i worse how much worse
am I now this is bad
he's just gonna beat me should I keep
there so it's rook rook and Bishop for a
night and pawn I mean I don't want to
resign because I think it's instructive
for the viewers how black not only how
black but how like this super GM can win
this position
let's not blunder blunder anything too
soon I'll play 94-94 some idea of
tricking him I have some idea also of
rook h7 rook aged 7 is a bit crafty does
it work I don't know if it works it
looks cool though
oh the promise Queen g1 King d2 Queen d4
that's unfortunate I have Brooke b7 as
well oh no rook b7 hangs some light
controls that square if I play 96
there's King f8 even King g7 this is so
bad that's probably my fault for for
calling earlier let's move back I used
so much time too
twenty-seven yeah I'm on the verge of
resigning I was watching one there's so
many tactics by Bischoff you - I'm gonna
try and be safe I'm hoping that he gets
careless so I've seen him blunder before
doesn't happen too often but sometimes
happens a queen III he's just about to
smash me I've rook b8 I'm just getting
smashed there is a rosen smash emo but
the Rosen smash it's meant for me to do
the Smashing oh not to get smashed let's
play Kim D - still alive I want him to
play c5 oh no I'm just there's so much
difficulty here let me be king c3 play
c5 allow me Bishop a4 I don't know why I
play d3 okay it's time to resign ah this
is a close match
I started off well I got good cards in
the beginning and now now he's up by a
thousand ships
[Music]
that's unfortunate so I lost my chip
lead
I was hoping to bullying him earlier
that's not happening I'm gonna check
this is below average hand hmm okay so
this is an interesting hand I think I'm
gonna check basically if I get a full
house also known as an empress then like
a pawn a pot a knight or a queen or
Potter Knight will be promoted to a
queen how many outs do I have it's more
than 50% on how the Queen next it's all
fall not gonna goes to crazy Bishop this
is like one of the worst hands was
valued at 11 if he bets I just fold oh
if he checks I'll check
I wonder if I should have Plouffe there
I don't know I haven't really bluffed
much should consider bluffing okay no
this is I don't think there's a hand
that's worse than this as if you're
dealt like three pawns the 3rd pawn gets
promoted to a rook the fourth and fifth
pawn gets promoted to a queen but it
seems like he also has pretty crummy
hand he's white so maybe I should I
don't know what I should do I should
pray that he doesn't help broker Queen
he has a queen okay okay I can resign
should I just resign let's um I'll place
the pieces in that instant resign
I don't know
how do I resign
oh it's not letting me until he moves
okay yeah I was pretty bad that was good
I didn't try and Bluff him because he
probably wasn't called like any
significant bet he had Queen and rook
yeah okay not the end of the world like
I still have a decent number of chips
I'm gonna try and keep the pot low I'll
still call maybe I should have folded I
don't know a few bets I just fold yeah I
should they're just folding right away
I'm still learning some strategy it's
tough like there there's a lot of a lot
of factors to take into consideration
that's uh yeah let's go again
okay two bishops this is a average
starting hand
I should like because because it's hard
to beat him in chess why must they raise
their yeah I've raised and then checked
oh this is actually not the greatest
hand Duffy if okay I'm giving up this
hand few bets I just for I was thinking
the strategy is to try and beat him in
in the budding stage he bets what's my
value is 15 slightly below average how
much should I put in the pot is only 400
the I fool it's a huge bag for that pot
there's almost three times the pots
[Music]
maybe I have to maybe mix it up in the
betting phase though so I'm being like a
little bit predictable I think okay two
nights now let's raise actually no let's
call raising I feel like would seem to
five-string and this hand is like
reasonably strong I'll call oh no that's
the only wants no oh if I get the third
night's weights what happens if I get a
third nights I've have four of a kind
basically I'm checking because this is I
could bet to which I bed and just bluff
him
let's Bluff pot please fold please fold
this is just a pure Bluff
please fold this is like the worst hands
oh I got in their pond this is the worst
hand right the only way to win this is
to bluff him but he okay he's like he
called that last bet I'm giving up this
is lonely he's like every hand beats me
here that's so unfortunate goes out for
days I don't know maybe I should have
bluffed should have been persistent like
going all-in
that would have been legendary I don't
know what to do I'm already like giving
up here basically I forgot it's possible
like to have a hand that leads to having
three pawns he's gonna see this card
this is my card cuz he sees a pawn was
print was demoted from a knight and he's
gonna be so confused and then he's gonna
see another pawn demoted from a knight
at least I'll win Connect four I'll win
Connect four and then resign as I move
first this is so bad he's a rook I
should I chose the wrong time to bluff
[Music]
okay I wouldn't connect four and now I
resign I can't resign on my turn oh man
this is rough
I'm wondering maybe it made sense to
bluff because he has to rush to rocks to
miners in a pawn
that's better than average it would have
put him in a difficult spot so now he's
like yeah he's gonna bully me now I just
have to find the right moment to like go
all in is it okay if I go all in and I
double up i'm i'm the chip leader again
but to double up it's probably gonna
require me to beat him in a chess phase
i don't want to commit myself I'll just
add small I'm drawing for basically a
queen if I got a pawn bishop or a queen
then I'll have a nice him yes okay let's
go oh wait oh it's promoted into media
so this is what I was hoping for
oh the betting still happens let's bet
the pot again what's valued at 17 I'll
bet a little bit more than the pots
trying to maximize my value I wouldn't
be surprised if he folds he might raise
I'm scared now so if he goes all-in he
probably has a queen but it's remember
it's like if I have a queen I think it's
like maybe something they said that he
has a queen he was 34% there's a whole
like odds guy it's somewhere okay here's
a pawn that's well he puts son g3 so he
knows I like to fianchetto let's change
up the strategy a little bit there
control the center I wonder if g3 was a
mouse lick oh I wonder if he was trying
to bluff me and now he's just giving up
he might just be giving up let's not do
that for the bishop Oh Waits
no he's White's have to be careful if
he's White's he might try and like make
sneaky threats I also have to move
quickly
okay seems like he just has a garbage
hand but he might have a queen we'll see
okay this is a very good sign ooh I
forgot about that
oh no I already messed up cuz I can't
put my bishop if he has the Queen I just
lose Oh Bishop g7 is such a bad move oh
this is so bad please don't have a queen
if he has a rook I'm okay but Queen on
a1 just wins for him
if he has it please don't have it no oh
he has it oh I feel so defeated because
I can't put like you can't have two
darks red bishops or love to put my
bishop on that face oh he lost
connection plot twist aha
not big enough of a plot twist this is
so sad what oh I can't even put it on on
c6 is the first two rings okay so he's
gonna take on g7 then I take on h2 and
he still has to work for it I wasted so
much time though it's so bad I'm
threatening maybe Queen Queen takes g3
of course maybe Queen g1 as well no it's
still a fight Queen a4 King f7 I
attacked the bishop I think I'm winning
the pawn actually and his pawn placement
was not so impressive he's taking his
time okay that's good sign
I have a lot of time to make up yeah I
expected he's gonna move the bishop back
I take wait can I just win the night
what is this well maybe he couldn't have
saved that I just win the night I'm
better now
I thought I was losing oh he has Queen
b3 I live c4 maybe I have to move
quicker let's plot the king I don't know
where to put the King maybe here and
then I take the pawn okay I want to keep
my pawns on dark squares because I they
do help kind of restrict the bishop
if I treat Queens endings should be
drawn I would think
but depends how I trade Queens I also
just have to move quickly
Queen g8 coming is he gonna bring us
came to c6 wait now if I take I think I
can take and force a draw right takes
now I don't know how to calculate these
positions takes if pawn takes its draw
if King takes King g7 and I keep doing
things yeah let's take and just hope it
works if I draw this it's a miracle this
East six probably even he five at some
point Oh kind of forgot about that move
let's bring the King to b7
hmm I have to calculate King b7 I feel
like I'm about to get sucks want to move
back the right moment I have to play
like he five i think ii 5 d5 27 seconds
king there I'm not liking this you see
for you have to go for a c4 and then
walk the King around I have 13 seconds
no that's not good
b5 Oh
each second okay I have to think on this
idea oh this doesn't even work though it
doesn't even work uh I'm gonna flag good
game naka I want it to like win the pawn
but it's not working I flag I could say
something good game oh that's rough good
game